Oh my god.
Omar,
how was your first lesson with the year
12 students?
Sean, Salman, Amon.
What's good? Omar, early rise and grind,
yeah?
Idris, innit?
Idris.
He's no good. You got to stay away from
that guy, man.
What is with all that singing and
chanting you keep doing in there? What
do you mean, praying? I can hear you,
Muslim mate, singing from my bedroom.
How do you expect me to relax?
You ain't got one of them next door to
you, have you? One of them?
Members of the MLBI and citizens of
Britain,
the real citizens,
native Britons.
We appreciate you taking the time to
come down to speak with us.
We are under attack. You see, on paper,
as you are right now, to most you'd seem
like an ordinary guy. But you and I both
know that's not who you really are,
Omar. You've got a dark past, secrets
that I'm sure would make your new
persona crumble to the ground if they
were let out. This is an absolute joke.
This book don't belong in here. You keep
your eyes forward, okay? You got me to
do it, Abby.
Or you'll have to rob a bank.
Mind telling me where the nearest one
is?
My uncle wasn't always like that. It's
all right. You don't have anything to be
sorry about.
think you understand.
The very thing that got me out of that
life is why they interrogated me in the
first place.
Oi, come here.
Probably screwed us getting caught by
the feds.
We're going to line him up for a
collect. I ain't down with Jamel or does
you?
Omar.
You murdered my boy, Omar.
You're my brother. I always got your
back, even when you don't have your own.